حيث ان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ارتكب 14
مجزره بحق عوائل فلسطينيه خلال 24 ساعه
الماضيه راح ضحيتها
165 شهيدا و250 اصابه بجراحات مختلفه كما
ان حصيله العدوان الاسرائيلي منذ السابع
من اكتوبر وحتى اللحظه ارتفعت الى
2672 شهيد
و561
جريح باصابات مختلفه كما اننا نؤكد بان
70% من ضحايا العدوان الاسرائيلي لازالوا
من الاطفال
والنساء كما ان الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه ضد
المنظومه الصحيه ادت الى استشهاد 312 من
الكوادر الصحيه جزء منهم كوادر صحيه
تخصصيه بتخصصات
نادره كما ان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تعمد
استهداف وتدمير 10 من سيارات الاسعاف
وخرجت عن الخدمه بشكل كامل كما ان
الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه ادت الى استهداف
142 مؤسسه صحيه وخروج 23 مستشفى و53 مركز
للرعايه الاوليه عن الخدمه
تماما كما ان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لازال
يعتقل 99 من الكوادر الطبيه في ظروف قاسيه
راسهم مدراء مستشفيات شمال قطاع غزه منهم
الدكتور محمد ابو سلميه مدير عام مجمع
الشفاء الطبي والدكتور احمد الكحلوت مدير
مستشفى كمال عدوان والدكتور احمد مهنا
مدير مستشفى العوده
بجباليا واكدت شهادات المواطنين الذين
اطلق سراحهم مؤخرا ان المعتقلين وخاصه من
الطواقم الطبيه يتعرضون للتعذيب الجسدي
والنفسي القاسي اضافه الى التجويع والعطش
وعدم النوم والاستجواب المستمر في البرد
الشديد كما اننا نؤكد بان بعد تعمد
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لتدمير مستشفيات شمال
قطاع غزه فان وزاره الصحه
وطواقمها نجحت في اعاده تشغيل مستشفى
الاهل العربي واصدقاء المريض ومستشفى
الصحابه ومستشفى الحلو الدولي وعدد من
مراكز الرعايه الاوليه رغم المخاطر
الكبيره التي تحيط بحركه وعمل الطواقم
الطبيه نتيجه القصف المستمر للاحياء
السكنيه ومحيط المؤسسات
الصحيه كما ان وزاره الصحه تبذل جهودا
حثيثه مع منظمه الصحه العالميه وكافه
الشركاء الامميين لاجراء تدخلات عاجله
وفاعله تضمن اعاده تشغيل مجمع الشفاء
الطبي ومستشفيات شمال غزه ونطالب باتخاذ
خطوات فاعله وعاجله لضمان حمايه كافه
المستشفيات وطواقمها وتامين طرق الوصول
اليها وخاصه في شمال قطاع غزه امام حاجه
800000 نسمه لازالوا يقطنون في تلك
المنطقه كما ان وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
تثمن دور الفرق الطبيه التي نجحت في
الوصول الى قطاع غزه لمسانده الطواقم
الطبيه في المستشفيات وتثمن تعاون مؤسسه
رحمه حول العالم في امريكا مع وزاره الصحه
بارسال فريق طبي متخصص ومساعدات طبيه
طارئه
ومطلوبه كما نطالب دول العالم والمؤسسات
الدوليه بارسال الفرق الطبيه والمساعدات
الطبيه المطلوبه والمستشفيات الميدانيه
لانقاذ الاف الجرحى في قطاع غزه كما نحذر
في وزاره الصحه من مخاطر المجاعه والجفاف
الذي يصيب اكثر من مليون و900 الف نازح
ومشرد يفتقدون لماوى المناسب والماء
والطعام والدواء
والامان من هؤلاء النازحين 50 ال سيده
حامل يعانين من سوء التغذيه والمضاعفات
الصحيه وخاصه ذوات الحمل الخطر في مراكز
الاواء نتيجه عدم توفر مياه الشرب
والنظافه الشخصيه والطعام والرعايه
الصحيه كما ان اكثر من 900000 طفل في
مراكز الاواء ايضا يتعرضون لمخاطر البرد
الشديد والجفاف وسوء التغذيه والامراض
التنفسيه والجلديه وعدم توفر التطعيمات
للمواليد حتى اللحظه كما ان الاطفال
والنساء يتعرضون لاضطرابات نفسيه متعدده
نتيجه القصف الشديد والدمار الاشلاء
وفقدان عدد منهم لذويهم
ومنازلهم كما نطالب المؤسسات الامميه
باجراء تدخلات عاجله لانقاذ حياه الاطفال
والسيدات الحوامل والمرضى المزمنين ومنع
الكارثه الصحيه والانسانيه والنفسيه في
مراكز
الايواء ان المساعدات الطبيه محدوده
ومقيده وغير متوافقه مع احتياجات
المستشفيات ونطالب كافه الاطراف بايجاد
اليات فاعله تضمن تدفق المساعدات الطبيه
وفق احتياجات وزاره الصحه المعلنه
والمرسله لكافه الجهات من اجل انقاذ الاف
الجرحى والمرضى في قطاع غزه كما اننا نؤكد
مجددا بان الاليه الحاليه لمغادره الجرحى
والمرضى لا تستجيب للاعداد الكبيره
والمتزايد من الجرحى وتساهم في قتل المزيد
من الجرحى يوميا وتستوجب اعاده النظر فيها
حيث لم تسمح بمغادره الا اقل من 1 في من
الجرحى حتى
اللحظه كما اننا بحاجه ماسه لمغادره اكثر
من
5300 جريح ومريض من الحالات الخطيره
والمعقده كاولو عاجله للعلاج بالخارج من
اجل انقاذ
حياتهم كما ان وزاره الصحه بحثت صباح
اليوم مع منظمه الصحه العالميه ايجاد
اليات فاعله مع كافه الاطراف لتسهيل خروج
الجرحى والمرضى للعلاج
بالخارج كما انها شكلت بالتعاون مع وكاله
الغوث وتشغيل اللاجئين ومنظمه الصحه
العالميه لجنه ثلاثيه لبحث خطه لتفعيل
واعاده تشغيل المراكز الصحيه لتلبيه حاجه
النازحين في كافه اماكن النزوح كما ان
وزاره الصحه تواصلت مع كافه المؤسسات
الدوليه وعلى راسها الامم المتحده ومنظمه
الصحه العالميه واللجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر من اجل زياره المعتقلين من الطواقم
الصحيه والانسانيه والعمل الفوري على
اطلاق سراحهم وفق القانون الدولي الانساني
واتفاقيه جنيف الرابعه رحم الله شهدائنا
وشفى الله جرحانا وحمى الله شعبنا من هذا
العدوان والتغول الصهيوني المستمر والسلام
عليك ورحمه الله وبكاته